ich habe ihn einmal gefragt ob er mir
mit der baby badewanne hilft und dann
hat er sich voll mit heißem wasser
gemacht und ich hab gesagt siehst du
verrückt das ist zu heiß ich kann das
baby so nicht baden
ach du hast keine ahnung dann hat er
mich geschubst und hat das baby genommen
und das heiße wasser getaucht der kleine
hat so geweint ich weinte er weinte und
ich konnte nichts machen und mir war
klar wenn ich weiter mit ihm streiten
würde dann bekomme ich noch eine ins
gesicht
[Musik]
ein dreh im frauenhaus hatte ich schon
mal ist immer etwas besonderes weil es
ein wirklich sehr sensibler
schutzbereich und schutzraum ist und die
geschichten die man da zu hören bekommt
sind einfach erniedrigen furchtbar
nicht nur für mich als frau für jeden
menschen
[Musik]
alles was am anfang so schön nett und so
süß war
und so wie ich es mir vorgestellt habe
das alles hat sich total schnell
geändert und sie waren schwanger zu denn
ich war schwanger
ja wir haben damals in einer sehr
kleinen wohnung gefunden es war oft so
dass er nach dem streit wenn er total
betrunken in seinem bett geschlafen hat
in dem ich keinen platz mehr hatte und
ich angst hatte dass haben mich zum
beispiel in diesem zustand schubst oder
sowas
dann habe ich auf dem boden in unserer
wohnung geschlafen total in tränen
und regelmäßig am nächsten morgen wenn
ich dann in den deutsch sprachkurs kam
hatte ich immer ein total geschwollenes
gesicht vom wein beim ihr sohn geboren
wurden und die heim monate später haben
sie habe ich ihn verlassen
er war irgendwo draußen und er ist
zurück nach hause gekommen und hat
angefangen zu streiten und hat dann
unseren sohn aus dem bett genommen
der kleine hat geweint und geschrien
eigentlich hatte er schon geschlafen
aber er wollte ihn mit ins andere zimmer
nehmen zum einschlafen
ich habe gesagt was machst du mit ihm
wenn du ihn zerquetscht oder sonst was
macht das bitte nicht ich bin hinter ihm
auf die knie gegangen und hab ihn
angebettelt er hat versucht mich mit dem
fuß zu treten sie sind wirklich auf die
knie gegangen wo die arminia erlebt und
ich versuche verzweifelt ich wusste
nicht mehr was ich machen soll dann habe
ich mein handy genommen den
wohnungsschlüssel und habe barfuß die
wohnung verlassen
das war um zwei uhr nachts
gewalt ist einfach egal von wem egal
gegen wen ist einfach unerträglich
und wenn man dann die geschichte von
einer schwangeren frau die von ihrem
mann ihrem ehemann geschlagen wird also
fällt eigentlich nicht so richtig ein
und trotzdem ist es halt wichtig dass
wir dahin gehen und darüber berichten
das ging ja nie ohne die protagonisten
ohne menschen und irgendwie auch
vertrauen und die aber auch ein
interesse daran haben darüber zu reden
weil sich vielleicht andere frauen
ermutigen sich auch hilfe zu suchen
[Musik]
lassen sich denn kinder durch sowas
relativ banales einfaches gut ablenken
wir versuchen halt hier an diesem ort
auch gespräche mit der mutter zu führen
damit das kind möglichst wenig in diese
gespräche involviert ist und hier gibts
halt mehr ablenkung die ganze
gewaltsituation die erleben die ja
tagtäglich in ihrer familie die kinder
kennen diese situation ist also eine art
normalität fast schon ja eine sehr
traurige normalität mit einer
13-jährigen gearbeitet
die hat mir erzählt dass die ist halt
jede nacht aufgeblieben um ihre mutter
vor den übergriffen des vaters zu
beschützen und die hat sich also sie hat
zu mir gesagt ich hatte das gefühl ich
bin schuld wenn ich eingeschlafen bin
und die hat es kognitiv versteht sie
dass es nicht ihre schuld ist aber
emotional ist es eben was anderes macht
ist das für die mutter noch schlimmer
weil sie das sieht was das auch mit den
kindern macht die mütter mit denen ich
hier arbeite die wünschen sich ja dass
ihre kinder unbeschwert aufwachsen und
ich weiß nicht wie oft ich schon in den
ersten aufnahme gesprächen von der frau
gehört habe als mit mir konnte er das
machen aber als ich gemerkt habe was das
mit meinen kindern nach das war für mich
die grenze dann ging es nicht mehr
derzeit wissen wir alle und sie ist ja
noch lange nicht vorbei auch wenn die
schulen jetzt wieder öffnen waren
natürlich viele kinder auch zu hause
also das heißt es gab keine flucht mehr
kein kein ausgleich
haben sie das hier auch gespürt da haben
wir am anfang von corona damit gerechnet
weil wir auch die zahlen kannte aus den
anderen ländern
dass jetzt die nachfrage sehr rasant
steigen würde und das ist ganz ganz
lange gar nicht passiert und wir haben
dann auch verstanden warum es war
nämlich so dass es in der notaufnahme
stelle viel mehr anfragen gab von frauen
die so etwas gesagt haben wie hey ich
bin halt im keller ich habe zehn minuten
zeit der typ ist die ganze zeit zu hause
ich kann überhaupt gar nicht irgendwie
hier weg was kann ich jetzt machen damit
ich heraus komme weil also nicht nur die
kinder zu hause geblieben
sondern natürlich auch der täter sind da
noch mal neue familien oder andere
familien dazu gekommen wo jetzt die
gewalt erst durch krone im stand kann
man das schon sagen ich weiß von keiner
frau und ich will nicht sagen dass sie
nicht existieren aber ich habe jetzt in
corona mit keiner frau geredet und habe
das auch nicht von meinen kollegen
gehört die gesagt hat feuer war alles
super und dann balkone und plötzlich war
der gewalt es gab schon vorher gewalt
und jetzt denken ja alle leute bei
gewaltige man schlagen und treten
und wir haben es aber mit gewalt form zu
tun die darüber hinausgehen und auch
vorher schon anfang also auch so
psychische gewalt immer fortwährender
demütigung
[Musik]
diese platten sind total beliebt kinder
besitzen die halt um damit häuser zu
bauen und das ist halt bei vielen
kindern auch diesen schutz element dass
sie sich ein haus bauen und dann
entscheiden wer geht da rein wer geht da
nicht rein was passiert hier gerade
und wenn du sagst hausbau es bedeutet
immer sicherheit
wie kommt es dass der ein oder andere
immer vor dem dunklen park wand und sagt
da findet sie gewalt statt und nicht vor
dem zuhause wenn frauen soweit erleben
sind das ja in der regel männer die wir
kennen und sich damit
auseinanderzusetzen ist ja viel
gruseliger als zu sagen der dunkle
parkes gefährlich und für frauen ist
aber das eigene zuhause die eigenen vier
wände sind statistisch gesehen die alle
gefährlichste ort auf der welt für eine
frau der dreh in einem frauenhaus ist
einfach schon mal auch aufgrund der
umstände etwas besonderes beachten zum
beispiel darauf dass wir als team kein
kameramann kein tonassistent dabei haben
sondern wirklich dass auch mit respekt
angehen zweite sache ist zum beispiel
auch noch bis kurz vorher gar nicht weiß
wo dieses frauenhaus eigentlich genau
ist bereits in schutz adresse ist und
ich bin aber froh dass wir doch immer
wieder auch über diese themen berichten
können gewalt ist einfach egal von wem
egal gegen wen ist einfach unerträglich
[Musik]
hallo freut mich hallo hallo mit dem
inselplatz
[Musik]
also der bruch alleine spricht nicht mit
uns sondern das ist das was wir dann
sozusagen einbeziehen müssen in die
gesamte in die gesamte betrachtung eines
falles aber es ist zum beispiel so dass
wir beim verdacht auf eine körperlich
körperliche misshandlung röntgenbilder
sozusagen alle knochen machen oder der
meisten knochen machen und dann sind
immer brüche die vorher noch nicht
bekannt waren schon auch im gewichtige
anhaltspunkte dafür dass da eine
körperliche misshandlung dahinter
stecken könnte und dann bis handlung der
körperlichen misshandlung ist in vielen
fällen ja nicht eine einzelne
körperliche misshandlungen die vorher
nie stattfindet und nachher nicht mehr
sondern es gibt ja ein hohes potenzial
für wiederholung ist jetzt an diesem
patientenzimmer irgendetwas anders als
an einem anderen patientenzimmer was
geräte anbelangt und gut ist natürlich
das ist ein bisschen kindgerecht gemacht
das ist normale ausgestattete
notaufnahme raum mit allem was
dazugehört mit anschlüssen und
untersuchungs liege und säuglings
untersuchung senna das mit auch richtig
für die jeweiligen wärmelampe ist heute
nicht so ganz richtig habe sonst schon
und hier eben untersuchungs instrumente
jetzt habe ich kopfkino das ist das ist
genau das
naja weil und warum wärme lang
egal warum wenn wir kleine also
säuglingen untersuchen müssen müssen wir
die entkleiden und damit ihr nicht so
schnell auskühlen machen wir um die
wärme lambach sowie jung war der jüngste
patient
wir haben patienten von 0 gesagt also
das noch wirklich dafür sind dass
kinderärzte eben auch sehen
jedes alter spektrum
[Musik]
also wenn wir über gewalt gegenüber
kindern sprechen reden hier in der regel
über sexualisierte gewalt über schläge
also physische gewalt was nicht zu
unterschätzen ist ist aber auch die
emotionale die verbale gewalt das ist
natürlich hier an dem ort eher
schwieriger zu greifen und zu sehen aber
auch dass etwas was ich von heute
mitnehmen das ist hier ein gutes team
ist also die vernetzung ist wahnsinnig
wichtig dass man sich eben über diese
dinge die man latenz spürt austausch
aber als mediziner der hier in der
kinderambulanz bleibt in seiner
kompetenz bleiben
und wofür journalistin dankbar bin ist
insbesondere bei diesem thema das uns
sich die türen öffnen denn dass es keine
selbstverständlichkeit man überschreitet
natürlich eine gewisse privatsphäre eine
grenze und ohne das könnten wir aber
auch nicht darüber berichten aber anyway
also gewalt gegen kinder ich kenne so
gut wie nichts was schlimmer ist und
dass ich hier auch wieder türen für uns
unser team geöffnet haben dass wir mit
betroffenen medizinischen personal
jahrhundert
geschenkt
[Musik]